[Music]
in easy homes news that's crazy
submitted by a patreon gang yay thank
you guys oh no it's not for you I was
not for me it's a homeless uh Kanye West
is trying to solve the housing crisis
but his neighbors keep calling the cops
huh I know this one better like why he's
building a village bro is he building
like a like a like a very low-income
housing unit next to his mansion or
something and the neighbors are like
don't do that basically yes oh they look
sick
they do look yeah photos I would love
for us to living together so then I can
dump my kids onto you guys when I don't
feel like taking care of pain oh how am
I gonna dump my kids when you're but
we're never gonna be mmmm
what that's we're on his land on his
property don't you that's his [ __ ]
property the Hidden Hills
he'll minica titties let's do where he's
going Hidden Hills at Calabasas this
property is so [ __ ] huge he's like
I'm I realize keep it where we're not
gonna dwell far out that means he could
have a fire in the middle and then it's
like so cool communal pot where you just
chuck meat in and everybody eats it
every day dope yeah so he's saying that
you wants to create like these low
income places or these homes for
low-income families so they can afford
and then I gotta look all tribal though
I mean he's working with architects
designing it too yeah so he's saying
that he wants to create this place to be
like a classless utopia and and his
mansion sits on the hill I know I always
do enjoy that his the domes they said on
a 300 acre plot that he owns
yeah they stand about fifty feet high
but the thing is that he has been having
construction go before like all hours of
the night but who's hearing this [ __ ]
300 acres yeah maybe he's like doing it
at the edge of the property where
there's neighbors that's more exactly
the line outside in he moves in I know
he couldn't like drove it all the way in
where there's no people and then did
this do my parents used to they had a
huge lot on like right next to a bunch
of our neighbors and they just use it as
a dumping ground because I told her my
parents are hoarders old [ __ ] cars
and [ __ ]
they get covered in weeds and like
cobwebs and [ __ ] they would dump they my
uncle dumped a trailer there like it was
not you see all kinds of mean letters
from people and but of course we're all
like well [ __ ] damn that's our land and
that's when I when I got old enough to
realize like wait a minute no my parents
are the white trash [ __ ] the
neighbors are like to the right ones had
a big piece of land do is not it's not a
big piece of land just a big lot oh yeah
that's cool though it's cool I want to
bake a lot like that you kind of have
about half of it like your backyard
right now there's about half of what
their law I need to double that I'll be
cool yeah you need yeah if I got a
shooting range in my backyard I'll be
sick my house right behind it where it'd
be honest you don't range please right
behind the shooting range just [ __ ]
take me man oh I want 300 acres 30 stick
a fork in on that yeah so kinase
building team said that the current
state of these structures these
prototype domes that they're just
temporary but they have been deemed
permanent by inspectors due to the
concrete platforms and so because of
that now they require specific building
permits before it construction can
continue
welcome to California real estate
doesn't what do you know when you're
like worried about hues of real estate
like he's trying to change the thing
that he wants to be the Howard Hughes of
even clothing and everything but I don't
know if he's gonna do it all one of
Howard's used you for real estate no the
Howard Hughes of real estate
that's not a great example because
Howard Hughes he [ __ ] up a lot of [ __ ]
and he was a recluse any peed in bottles
he was a germaphobe so does he want to
be a germaphobe you also have to be that
Henry Ford of cart like don't get us
started on [ __ ] Henry Ford man bored
of how of housing yeah yeah like this
we're probably just like scratching so
every five minutes really not around
astronomy which one make him sound we're
like how he's I thought he had a real
problem of Jews like who Henry Ford I
think right here maybe it was both I
wouldn't be surprised I think everyone
of that generation had a problem with
Jewish people yeah so he tweeted last
year he said we're starting a yeezy
architecture armed called easy home Wow
easy
Oh architects and industrial designers
who want to make the world better so I
was dicta music man and so now he's made
it
but what if he does something really
[ __ ] amazing if he doesn't good for
him to show you guys um concept photo of
the inside what's better than [ __ ] my
house concrete yeah
and it looks cold that day for everyone
in Rome made with like pre oh okay with
that cremation more cost-efficient
mm-hmm
prefabricated thank you pre fabric thank
you is that bark on the floor what is
that
what sannan-san and rocks yeah rocks
[ __ ] remember those the cult on Game
of Thrones the ones that oh yeah that
try to kill Cersei all the sparrows look
it reminds me of those [ __ ] would
live there oh yeah the inside
it's a classless society where we're
[ __ ] Kanye's the almighty Lord it's
pretty sick that's so good
you sound jealous thousand percent
jealous she's been hiding it [ __ ] yeah
I mean think about it like those are my
dreams I want to call like he's doing
what I want to do it doesn't really
cause a great men on the list so much
what is that the kitchen it looks
unfinished
oh if a low housing income was better
mine at this point I'll put all my jobs
on housing yeah but we're all the people
poor people gonna put their [ __ ] in
fast food there's nowhere to put their
fast there's a counter eat your cabbages
he's not even thinking about the water
about where my spam gonna go I'm pretty
sure he's gonna allow them to have
furniture okay
maybe you furniture how many people per
unit is home and like you know he calls
his home the sunken place it doesn't
make his house like that it's also super
minimalist - mm-hmm you guys like
minimalism it's like when you do that
just don't plan that [ __ ] it looks like
they have [ __ ] Isis torturing
sessions in that van a little bit you
guys are weird
I do like his [ __ ] Hut though his
hunt his Hut - don't I want to see what
that looks like that you're gonna be
wearing a loincloth no I would be the
first [ __ ] to join hell yeah I
think the the mandatory clothing is
animal fur if you live there I mean
these clothing already looks like that
what if he's trying to recreate Lord of
the Flies like he's creating his own
like social experiments he's like
actually one of those evil scientists
say he sets off an alarming says the
last person surviving gets to live in my
movie that's going down yeah I just kill
myself yeah on a spot I would just trap
myself to your back so you can protect
me you're great
for days as a meat shield I'm already
dead just have tips dead body on my
front I'm real I'm ready yeah I can see
where you're in the front Gina's a
backpack yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] human
shields
you know that cat those draped over a
watermelon that cycle on your head is
helmet no they're on your head doesn't
be at home with me and then we're just
in Viet safety and watch mom and do some
kanji yeah I believe that you could
geode contributed herself as tribute she
volunteered
I can't we've kind he's not build an
amusement park that's just called by
honey well anyway here's like the smiles
I think he would accidentally smile like
him one that wouldn't clip of him boy
lucky that I picture Kanye land to be
like the entrance it's just his face and
its mouth open and then you walk through
inside of the Kanye's face see and
there's rides like in his easy shoes oh
that sounds yeah it's whole body just
laying down like that was feeding you
shoes like the teacup yes what is it
dick do you have to go there to find out
hi Beast everywhere would love this
[ __ ] amusement park well I'm gonna
get wet in there though
nice yeah it's a wet ride like you oh
yeah so I don't know I'm really curious
to see how these places are gonna turn
out because me - what is it unexpected
information it has ceiling mirrors that
make it look like you have Kim's but I
would love that
then you walk out and you do have Kim's
book they did [ __ ] to you in there all
like you get surgery for free yeah oh
it's kind of cool and cool man I'm
starting to like Kanye now again right
what do they put in her but by the way
wealthy they can suck fat and put it in
there but they can also inject it with
like silicone seal well she did get an
x-ray of her butt to show that she
doesn't have Scylla but you can tell
what it is though like her body like she
has a small frame and then like she has
this weird light but like a whisper -
yeah and then her little legs there so
she got a [ __ ] mantle dude you could
like hang a stocking on that thing weird
one of the articles they referred they
referred to Kanye as Kent Kim
Kardashian's husband no I'm like wow
this woody who's more popular you think
Kamkar - right now public
I think in for sure honey hasn't put out
music yeah but dude his music is like
[ __ ] huge it is and he'll play
forever she's relevant like always it's
more worldwide famous Kanye or Thank You
Kim she's in though she does uh clothing
she does makeup like she's she's
everywhere she has a show still she does
kimonos popular who do you think who do
you think is more popular in China Kim
or Kanye Kanye get in China can you just
give me a Kanye for what Kanye thank you
but we're though but we're maybe there
you go how about that thank you I don't
even know why I wanted the crazy Kim
influenced millions of women to get
plastic surgery to look like her how
wild is that I'm gonna make a trend yeah
a whole entire Instagram makeup phase or
trail life is her I don't blame her
though I was even crazier is that Paris
like taught her everything she knows so
it was really Paris as well I blame the
media for putting her face [ __ ]
everywhere I know I always feel a little
bit ashamed of myself when I'm looking
for articles and I see something more
like the Kardashians and I'm just like I
have to look good why I don't know I
don't know not why you click and I know
you CLE but why are you embarrassed
oh because I'm like this is not
important why do I care about it because
she's a genius as she knows how to get
that from you a good little escapism
though I I actually try to fight it off
because I'm like no I'm better than that
I'm Logan I go for me like a Kim
advocate I think she's a I love kiss
she's a [ __ ] Gino Hey you're a
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] if you ever think well
she only made a porn tape and that's all
she's known for yeah if you're angry at
Kim you're being [ __ ] place yeah true
just to clarify like no no no no I'm not
talking about you I'm just saying that
the people out there who are sitting
there just fuming like I hate this
person I can't resist what protection
there's a lot of people getting she
knows how to play on people's egos you
hurt her Chris whatever business
geniuses they are yeah
I think I want to do it for me but I see
what they're doing and I'm all like oh
my god the way you can play people and
you could stay in their minds is amazing
yeah every time I dice out a little bit
something new happens my haunting new
killer comes up I hate you because of
that reason oh wait I hate you so much
he's building Joe Molly oh you're just
so jealous I know I'm jealous
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]